what am I going to talk about today I
want to talk about web you eyes which is
itself sort of weird because I work at
James Street we are a trading firm we
are not a web company our business is
not presenting web user interfaces to
third parties so why do we care about
this well we care about it because we
need to build user interfaces for
ourselves we're a prop trading firm
which means we our business is running
our own trading strategies on the
world's electronic exchanges and that is
an intensely technological affair and
intensely data-driven affair and that
means we need user interfaces that
reflect that and that in particular are
good at dynamically transforming and
interacting with complex data sets and
that's the kind of problem that is going
to drive what I want to show you and I'm
going to talk about some techniques to
make it easier and better to build these
kind of applications but before I go
into the how I want to talk a little bit
more about the why and in particular let
me bring up really small font size what
looks like the world's most boring user
interface it's a table so I want to
actually highlight that exactly not
quite as boring as it seems first of all
it's like kind of interactive so I can
like click on things navigate around I
can edit stuff and that you know updates
the data I can search for things and the
techie is a filter so if I do this
actually dynamically narrows down the
view to a subset of the data I can
decide oh there's some of these dynamic
values here but I want to sort on one of
them so now it's sorting on these values
as they're dynamically changing which
means in some cases you'll see the rows
move up and down over time and I guess
another point we're saying is there's a
lot of data so like like really a lot of
data like there's like a hundred
thousand rows in here
and it all renders pretty zipa lee in
that context and oh and the data is
changing it's maybe not obvious how much
it's changing but if I scroll by if I
sort by this field and put the moat this
now is sorted by most recent time of
update so like there's a lot of stuff
going on here
and even so it's all still kind of zippy
so why is that well there's a lot of
algorithmic stuff going on work that's
being done to make this perform well and
to get a sense of what's going on oh
that's a terribly false Mont a sense of
what's going on here it's useful to kind
of look at the inspector to see what's
actually happening so here let's open up
and look at the actual table itself okay
so here are the rows so you can sort of
see these are the rows that show up in
the table and I said there were like a
hundred thousand but that doesn't look
like a hundred thousand but a few what
happens when I scroll you'll see like
some rows are being added to the bottom
and taken off the top and then actually
if you look at the very top there's this
height field so basically what's going
on is the UI is detecting where we're
scroll to and it understands the height
the proposed height of all the elements
and where they are all located in space
and picks out the set of things it needs
to render and knows the size of the
things it's not rendering so it can like
fold that together and compute the
height and just stick that there all for
the purpose of minimizing the amount of
stuff you throw at the Dom right the Dom
itself is this tree like imperative API
in which you express to the browser what
is it that you would like it to show to
the user and so like Phil ting filtering
sorting transforming interacting there's
like a lot of stuff going on and a lot
of optimization going on and that's all
kind of complicated to do like I don't
know how many of you have tried to build
a like highly data intense reactive UI
like this but you can do it in a kind of
straight-ahead way but it's like
slamming your head into a wall to do it
because what you need to do is a kind of
detailed incrementalization of the
program that you're building because you
eyes and general are kind of an
incremental programming problem which is
the thing we'll talk about more in a
second and doing that by hand really
sucks like it's just an unpleasant
programming idiom it's hard to get right
I I like this a nice analogy which have
you ever heard of dead reckoning dead
reckoning is a way of navigating what is
dead reckoning it's when you you're
going around to keep track of how fast
you're going and what direction you're
going and you add it up you integrate
you sum together all the little moves
to figure out where you are and the
reason dead reckoning is terrible like
you do it when you need to but it's the
worst kind of navigation because the
errors build up it's easy to make
mistakes along the way and you sort of
don't know where you are on the map and
what I want to talk about is a
programming idiom that lets you program
in this way that's both highly efficient
and lets you understand where you are in
that map and talk in natural map
coordinates rather than talking about
the sum of a bunch of tiny little
changes so that's kind of the goal so
before I get to the techniques I want to
talk about I guess one other thing I
should say so James Street is also weird
in a number of ways one of them is we
use Oh camel as our primary language for
everything including web UIs so all of
this whole talk is going to be about
libraries are implemented in Oh camel
and I'm going to throw up some cordon
code on the board in okay well I'll try
to explain it you're not expected to
understand how to peer through the
syntax but it's kind of there to help
you navigate what's going on I do think
the ideas here are transportable you
should be able to take these and apply
them in other languages in other
contexts so with that said before I go
into the techniques I want to say
something about how to approach this
problem the problem of expressing a UI
nicely before we talk about the
optimization bit and so the whole talk
in some sense hangs upon an unsupported
assertion which is the topic of this
slide which is that the thing I'm about
to show you is a nice way of expressing
you eyes happily this is not novel this
is not something we've come up with this
is really just a ripoff of some mix of
Elmen react and other similar kind of
techniques so I'm just going to kind of
briefly explain our kind of spin on this
which is not in an important different
from what you'll find in the Elm and
react worlds and if you don't believe
it's a good idea go talk to Evan
Zablocki or a Jordan walk or someone
like that I'm not going to defend that
here but I'm going to try and explain it
so the basic approach for how you model
a UI so it's going to be highly
functional in style and it's organized
around three different types the model
the virtual Dom and the any action type
so the virtual Dom is in some sense the
simplest one to explain the virtual DOM
is an immutable data type that
represents the Dom you wish you had
right it's just it's not this imperative
tree of things it's your own separate
immutable data type to use for
representing what you would like to put
into the DOM and that is a shared data
type that any UI you're going to build
with this approach is going to use and
then the other types model and action
are types that are specific to the
particular application you're building
the model is essentially the data model
that you have that determines what you
want to show people it doesn't have all
the presentation details in it but it
has all the core information from which
those presentation details can be
derived and then the action represents
state transitions updates to your model
and there's a this kind of the arrows
and the diagram represent the basic flow
through which this application goes so
you start out with a model you apply
what we'll see is just a simple function
from your model to produce the virtual
Dom that you want to display the virtual
Dom contains within it callbacks to be
registered with the Dom which are
essentially used to trigger actions
those actions are then applied to the
model to update it and that again
updates the virtual Dom so that's the
basic loop and in that loop the
interactivity of the UI is found right
so that's the kind of core
representation there and this here is
what that looks like in Oh camel so here
is a signature that you can fill out in
order to be an app in this environment
you need to provide two types the model
and the action and two functions apply
action which tells you how to update the
model when an action occurs and render
which takes the model and produces a
virtual Dom okay so I'm not going to
again go into more details about exactly
how this works and really the heart of
the rest of the talk is how to optimize
these functions and in particular we're
gonna really focus on the render
function the one that goes from the
model to the virtual Dom and how to do
that in an efficient and as it turns out
incremental away and so this gets to the
heart of the thing I was saying before
you really want to think of UI as an
incremental computation and what I mean
when I say an incremental computation is
one that is efficient not just at doing
the entire end-to-end
computation but in refreshing that
computation when the input to the
computation changes in small ways and
this is unsurprisingly when you think
about it at the heart of the user
experience at many different UIs because
there's a lot of data that goes into the
initial render that says all of the
things you need to show the user but
when things change and you eyes are all
about dynamic interaction when things
change they typically change in small
ways not everything flips all at once
small parts of the data model small
parts of the interaction state that says
where you're focused in what you're
pointing out little bits change and
those little bits should be cheap to
apply and freshen up the world with and
so the following the follow troupe
that's not helpful so the following a
little picture kind of gives you a sense
of what the basic computational pipeline
is you start with a model you then
compute the virtual Dom with a pure
function from that model and now because
this is say our first render there's the
Dom tree in the browser it ain't right
yet it's the whatever it is and not what
we want it to be so we have some
function this is now an imperative
function that takes the virtual DOM and
slams the Dom itself to match your
intent so that's like step one and then
what happens when in action occurs and
you get a new model Prime which is
different from the original model well
you could do this right maybe we can
henceforth called a stupid thing which
is to just recapitulate the entire
computation recompute the virtual Dom
from scratch slam it into the Dom from
scratch
so that's terrible we don't want to do
that in fact no one who uses virtual DOM
does that what they do instead is they
take advantage of the fact that the
change is small so this is an
incremental computing trick and just as
a you know notes to you guys who might
be looking at some UI frameworks
somewhere buried usually somewhere
inside the documentation where they
don't want to show it to you because
it's a little ugly buried in every user
interface toolkit is an incremental
programming system sometimes not very
good sometimes well-thought-out but like
it's in there somewhere and you should
understand how it works when you're
thinking about which system you want to
work in so for these virtual Dom based
systems a standard trick is
to take advantage of the fact that the
model probably changed only a little bit
so the virtual Dom probably changed only
a little bit so the Dom should probably
only have to change a little bit so we
compute a diff right a diff between the
virtual DOM and the duttan had the
previous virtual DOM and the new virtual
DOM and that diff is essentially a set
of instructions it tells you how to
update the old virtual Dom to get the
new virtual Dom or transpose slightly
how to update the Dom to get the Dom
that we want to have so there's a kind
of parallel transport of this little
arrow over to apply that so it's
logically that same little arrow to the
Dom so nothing new here totally standard
trick that's not the portion of the
diagram I really want to talk about I
really want to talk about this orange
arrow and the orange arrow like I want
to do the same thing on the model side
for a small UI you can kind of get away
with just using the virtual Dom because
that minimizes this most expensive thing
which is like talking to the browser
render engine and making it do things
but the recomputation of the entire
virtual Dom is not so hot if the virtual
Dom is big if the K if the model is big
or the virtual DOM is big well that's
not going to work so well and so you
want some way of optimizing both of
these arrows and the arrow on the left
is harder right the arrow on the right
is optimizing a computation on a single
standard data type doing a single thing
whereas on the left hand side well the
model the model is actually a totally
custom chosen by the user data structure
and so how we take advantage of the
similarities in the old model on the new
model is not nearly so clear and
incrementalization stories are uglier
when we talk about that part and so the
focus of this talk is going to be about
trying to understand a different kind of
approach for getting this
incrementalization done so what we're
specifically going to do is we're going
to achieve our increment ality at first
with a library called
incremental so this is a library that
we've developed at James Street we've
had it for a long time it was actually
developed not for this application it
was developed for all sorts of different
systems that we were building and we
only later thought oh we could like
compile this and run it in the browser
because we have a JavaScript back-end
and so the very same library has you've
done a lot of different purposes on
a bunch of different platforms the basic
idea of incremental is you basically
capture a trace of your computation in
the form of a dependency graph that gets
built up as your computation unfolds and
then when you rerun the computation as
some of your inputs change you use this
trace to compare what you need to do now
with what you did last time and that
allows you to just refire subsets of the
computation rather than having to redo
everything if you use Excel the Excel
model is a little bit like this you have
a bunch of cells each one of them has
equations the equations can refer to
other cells if you used Excel much you
have a big complicated sheet you modify
just like some piece of it it doesn't
have to freshen up by recomputing
everything it essentially computes the
transitive closure of the parts that
have been dirty but the parts have been
changed and just refires those and that
at the heart of it is the kind of core
optimization in incremental is built
around and this is actually based on yet
older work when we took our at CMU did
it for his dissertation work on what's
called self-adjusting computations and
incremental is more or less in
implementation of self-adjusting
computations inside of the ocala
framework so I want to explain the core
of this API I could explain it by saying
oh it's a monad but that's like a really
lame explanation so instead what I'm
going to do is walk through the core
Combinator's one by one and try and give
you a sense of what they're useful for
and in particular what they do at the
level of the graph so the first one is
map here is the type signature of map so
again obscure syntax you don't know let
me walk you through it so here you take
in a incremental which is to say an
incremental that computes a value of
some unknown type a and a function from
s to B's and it gives you a be
incremental so this is taking
incremental apply a transformer give me
a new incremental so how do we use this
well imagine we have an application
where there's a base model and we want
at the end of the day to render two
components on the screen at the same
time each of which derives from a
different sub model there's like two sub
models and two sub components
come out of this and then we want to
stick that together on the same page so
we can apply map twice to build the two
subcomponent crow Mentos representing
the two sub components by essentially
projecting out the part of the model
that we care about for this case and we
can then use map again to take the model
which again is just like this pure data
representation and do whatever
transformation is required to compete to
convert it into the necessary virtual
DOM and now we're stuck because map can
fan out but it can't fan in so we need
to add another Combinator this one is
called map two and as the name suggests
it takes two incrementals in a
incremental and the B incremental and a
function that takes an A and a B in
returns to C and gives you back a C
incremental so which way of merging two
things together and we're going to in
this case use this to merge together the
two different virtual Dom's with a
function that basically just takes the
two trees and like slops them together
in some little you know HTML ash
environment in which they're both going
to reside and now you have what looks
more or less like a complete graph
representing the computation for
building a page and of course why do we
want to graph we want to graph for its
optimization property so let's talk
about what happens when we make a change
so if we update the model what happens
well every node when it changes when is
rather when it fires which will fire
when you just manually direct the apply
change to it when it fires you see
either did that modification actually
change it or is it equal to the old
value if it's equal to the old value it
cuts off the computation ends there if
it's different it propagates to all its
children so we're gonna wake up sub 1
and sub 2 there gonna redo the
projections out for the model and let's
say just sub 2 change
sub 1 is exactly as it was before so
that means the sub 1 incremental is
going to is now going to cut off it's
not gonna fire again but subdue 2 will
continue and it's going to fire through
the rest of the graph and there you go
we have some increment ality we've have
two components sitting side by side
inside the same application but when
only when the data for one of them
changes we don't have to fire the other
computation right so
incrementality achieved okay so those
are our first two operators the next
operator is called bind and with bind
we're gonna solve a slightly different
problem here again we have two
components but and we're gonna build up
those components in the same way using
map but now we're going to want to have
a page which shows one or the other
depending on which mode we're in which
is like a totally standard thing you
have some UI that has multiple different
views you can flip between so we're
gonna use a bi node for that let's look
at the signature of bind it is
surprisingly similar to map you take an
a incremental and then a function that
takes an A and returns not a B as with
map but instead a B incremental and then
the whole thing gives you back a B
incremental so the idea here is the
function instead of just taking a value
and producing a simple value it can take
a value in return in incremental
computation in fact it could select from
multiple different ones that already
exist and that's what we're going to do
here so here we add the thing that takes
the V Dom and it binds on the model and
then let's say it decides based on where
the current state of the model that is
going to pull it in the data from V da
one and put that on the page so it does
so so now if there are changes to the
model that effect component two well
that part of the graph is qui asked it's
not going to run anymore so we don't
have to pay for that firing at all and
if there are changes that affect
component one then they're going to flow
through and then if the model changes
such that it now wants to show two
instead of one we're going to cut the
connection from one and add a connection
to do and now the firing structure is
reversed now changes to two will
propagate and changes to one will be cut
off and dropped on the floor okay so
this gives us a very straightforward
notion of dynamism in the graph so the
map stuff gave us static graphs the bind
gave us dynamic graphs in fact let's
stop for a moment and like think a
little bit about what we have done so
far in the talk as I said map has given
us the status static structure and bind
gives us a form of dynamism but the form
of dynamism is in some ways somewhat
limited so the form we saw in the
previous slide was just selecting among
multiple pre-existing things that's not
the only thing you can do you could also
allocate whole new computations inside
of a bind
that turns out to be useful but that
form of dynamism is not it's somewhat
limited in itself is not easy to use in
a highly incremental way which is when
you allocate new computations on the
right-hand side of a bind
well you're allocating a whole new
computations you're not getting to reuse
anything from the past so you have
dynamism but the incrementality of that
is compromised and if you just step back
for a second and see what have we gotten
out of this model if you're familiar
with things like Elmen react we've
gotten more or less the things that
those systems give us which is you can
take your thing you can break it up into
components you can kind of control which
components are shown you can restrict
the changes such that changes to one
component don't force the renders of
different components and that's kind of
that here's what it doesn't tell you a
good way of doing how about
incrementally sorting 10,000 things like
it's just not clear how you can like
break things into components and cut off
stuff and thereby sort a big set of
things right so there's there's a limit
to the kinds of transformations we can
effectively do and that's in some sense
the heart of what I want to talk about
is how can we build abstractions which
let us build more dynamic more
interesting kinds of data
transformations that are still
incremental at their core so here's
another type signature I hope you're not
too sad about seeing type signatures yet
it gets worse when I start writing code
so this is a function we're calling
inker map and now I have to take a
moment to apologize for a general
functionally functional programming
nomenclature car-crash which is map and
map so there's at least two arguably
more meanings of map on the page one the
capital map map T is a finite map it's a
mapping from keys to values in like a
concrete tree like functional data
structure and then we're talking about
mapping over an incremental value and
we're also going to talk about mapping
over a map and mapping over an
incremental map so that this second kind
of map is all about transforming the
thing inside of a container and
incrementals are kind of containers or
maps of kind of containers and so like
anyway I apologize for how much
sounds like I'm stuttering and saying
that Matt Matt Matt Matt just I'll try
and be clear where I can about what the
meaning of these things are so what are
we doing here we have the input of the
function is a map incremental so it's an
incremental node that just contains a
data structure that is a map that
contains key value pairs the type is K
the value is v1 of type v1 and then we
have a function from x v1 to v2 and the
output we want is another incremental
math except now the data has been
transformed the data type is v2 instead
of v1 and it's basically the obvious
result you should get by transforming
all of the data and this is actually
like writing a function that meets this
signature is easy here is a function
that meets this signature so there's a
little bit of syntactic nonsense here
this let % map is basically syntactic
sugar for nicely using the incremental
level map function so roughly you can
think about what's going on here is
we're saying everything after the now
highlighted line will be rerun every
time m CH angel am a p-- and you'll get
the map in its current state to look at
and compute on so the graph structure we
get is something like this there's the
map we start with as M prime we're
computing and has the following lovely
incremental structure which is every
time you change m you recompute m prime
from the beginning so this does not in
fact do us any good we have met the type
but we have not met the desired
performance characteristics right we've
used incremental in a totally trivial
way and it's not obvious what we can do
just given the combinators we have at
our disposal to do something better than
this right this is I don't know what
like static set of things I can do to
map out different parts of the map and
project them into different little
incrementals like that is this does not
seem like a productive way to go and
what we're going to do in the end is
we're going to take advantage of diff
ability right the fact that functional
data structures often admit efficient
diffing algorithms so this is the
signature of the symmetric difference
and 'red library which pre we had
pre-existing all of this
web browser UI nonsense because it was a
natural thing to want for other reasons
and symmetric gift aches as an argument
to different maps with the same type for
keys and values and inequality function
for comparing the key for the data and
it returns to you a sequence of results
which are Keys annotated by what
happened between the first map and the
second map and left says there was a key
in the second map but not in the first
right says it was in sorry love says it
in the first but not the second right
says it was in the second but not the
first and unequal says it was in both
but with different values so this
roughly corresponds to add delete and
change right if and this operation is
super quick in particular if the two
maps you're applying them to the second
map is one that was derived by doing
some set of efficient operations from
the first map then for various reasons
having do with how persistent data
structures work in order to do that
transformation efficiently really most
of the physical memory is shared between
the two maps you just had to like update
the spine a few times to add new entries
so the symmetric diff algorithm takes
advantage of the fact that if two
subtrees are physically the same pointer
you know that everything underneath them
is exactly the same so you can
short-circuit the computation of the
diff which means that roughly speaking
the the cost of computing the diff is
asymptotically the same as the cost of
having made the changes in the first
place so this runs fast
you don't have to walk over your entire
data structure to do this operation so
now we want to take this idea and embed
it inside of the incremental context and
as we'll see one of the nice things
incremental does is even when you're not
doing all of your work as part of the
incremental graph it's a really useful
coordinating mechanism to hook together
lots of different computations so we
need a hook and that hook is going to be
a function called diff map so the idea
of diff map is it's a map that gives you
access to the previous value of the
computation that you run so if you have
an a incremental it produces a B
incremental along with a function but
it's not like the normal function of a
maps to be if it has that to it has a as
an input and B as now but it has an
extra input which is
the optionally provided previous version
of the computation so it's like if you
could use the thing you did last time to
optimize your current computation you
should feel free to do so and this map
itself is not a complicated thing to add
we don't have to look hard at this
implementation to understand it I mostly
want to highlight that it's pretty short
and that basically what it does is some
dirty tricks about capturing a little
bit of mutable state inside of the
closure that's used for the
transformation and that's what that
mutable state is used for capturing the
previous version of the computation and
then and this slide you really are not
supposed to understand again this is the
whole implementation of the inker map
that we started with so we call diff map
on the original map we have this
function now that has the old version
optionally and the map it's supposed to
depend on we pattern match on the map on
this old version if there's nothing
there's no old version which is true in
the first run well we just do that all
at once computation that's fine if we
have the old input and the old output
then we compute the actual symmetric
diff and then we fold over that diff and
do different things depending on what
case we're in in the left case which is
a key that was in the left but not the
right so that's the deletion case we
just removed that corresponding key from
the output in the unequal or right case
there's a new thing we want to add so we
just do map dot set we add in that new
binding but we apply the function f to
the data before stuffing it in so we
sort of take the diff on the left hand
side and transform it into a diff that
can be applied to the right hand side
right so far so good and what's nice
about this is it's actually a very
general-purpose thing we're not really
in an important way specialized to map
we were able to do this oh no we're able
to do this because it's a difficult Atta
structure and lots of functional data
structures are difficult so this is a
pretty general-purpose trick but there's
more we want to do right we can't build
that a whole complicated UI described
with the just this trick here's another
very useful trick so we call this
imaginative Lee incur map Prime and this
is almost not different from the
increment basically the difference is
the transformation function instead of
being a simple all at once
transformation from this form of the
data to that form of the data it itself
is an incremental computation
so now what we're essentially doing is
instead of just doing a single
transformation we're setting up an
incremental pipeline for each element in
the data and this kind of nested
incrementality is often important in
more complicated cases where you have
complex nested data and you want to
employ a handle it incrementally at
multiple levels so we're not going to
implement this with diff map this is
more complicated than that if you want
to think about why it's more complicated
you just need to think about the graph
structure that's necessary to do this
thing so here we have M on the left and
M Prime on the right and this is more or
less than necessary graph structure for
the performance properties we want which
is we need to fan out to all of the
different entries in the data and then
feed those entries into these
incremental pipelines I was talking
about and then take the result the e
Prime the transformed entries and merge
them in back together and if you think
about the propagation structure well mmm
gets modified and listenig is modified
with an add to a single L or rather an
update to a single key well we want to
fire through just that key right just
the part of the graph that corresponds
to that key and that like violates seem
very and I told you before remember I
said like we modify a thing and if it
changes then all of its children get
woken up well and you sort of need that
in the ordinary case because how does
the child know whether or not it's
computation has changed so in this case
we have to be able to build a
special-purpose computation that in a
data specific way understands things
about the nature of maps and how they
change and knows things about the
specific transformation to be able to
pick and choose which of its
dependencies actually need to be refire
so if we all we have our bind in map and
map to we are dead in the water they are
not expressive enough to build the graph
that we need so the thing you need to
build a graph you need is like a little
ugly unfortunately which is to say we
kind of like you know took like a little
piece of middle of like you know knocked
out some of the interface and expose an
expert API to incremental to allow you
to build these things that give you kind
of lower level access to the graph
structure and that's not an interface
you want everyone to program with but
happily you can find useful primitives
that you can build on top of that lower
level interface that themselves are
really nice and let you do all sorts of
useful things and two of those nice
primitives we call
split and join these are for maps in
particular and well there you go you see
the type signature what else do I have -
well ok by staring long enough at the
type signature you can sort of get it
but it's better to talk it through so
the idea is split takes an incremental
which contains a map and gives you an
incremental that contains a map but
where the data part of the map itself
contains an incremental computation and
the idea now is that changes to the the
input map that just update a key are
routed directly to the inner incremental
and changes that add or remove keys that
then need to change the spine of the map
those go to the outer incremental and
this more or less corresponds to the
fan-out phase of that graph we're
talking about you kind of break up into
a bunch of little incremental and you
can control the addition and removal of
those which you need to be able to do in
this structure and then join is of
course just the reverse right it has its
exactly the inverse of split and it just
has the reverse type for that reason it
just takes a two-level incremental map
and flattens it into a one level
incremental map and then joyously inker
map prime is just written like this we
split we increment we join and that
gives us this richer structure right
there and you can build in Chrome App
Prime that way and you can build a whole
bunch of different operations in the
same style and I think this is kind of a
thing that you notice over and over and
this work is there are some like core
pieces that are hard but you can build
on top of them beautiful easy to reuse
abstractions that can be used over and
over again in a way that's easy for
people to understand so just to kind of
gather what we've done here we've
extended incremental in the number of
ways we added diff map which all it
required is you know the stomach to
stick a little mutable peace and closure
somewhere and now we have a
general-purpose trick that works on any
difficult Atta structure and then we
built split and join on top of this
expert interface and in fact we really
have two modules here there's inker map
which contains split and join a number
of other map specific operation and
another one we built was incre select
which lets you do things like thinking
about selecting ranges of things and
dealing with things like focus comp you
which are also useful to handle in this
way so we've now built a number of
different useful abstractions on top of
this same core system and that these
kind of abstractions have helped us
build the kind of complex API is that we
were talking about so what are things to
remember from this talk there's just a
few key observations that I want you to
take away one is UI design is an
optimization problem
it's an algorithms problem and it is
best handled when you think about it
that way that way and in fact the real
trick the thing that gives you the most
bang for the buck is to think about it
as a problem where you can separate out
the sort of nasty low-level painful
problem of building a highly efficient
UI that does exactly what you want into
two beautiful problems one is the
problem of specifying the UI you really
meant in a clean functional way and the
other is the problem of building
efficient algorithms that make that
possible and it's a lovely thing when
you can take an unpleasant problem and
break it into two high-class interesting
problems like taking the right frame on
this really helps you do that another
thing I want to convince you of is
self-adjusting computations of which
incremental is an example is a powerful
optimization tool and a powerful kind of
organizing tool it helps you build a
complex set of different views on your
data that all keep in sync in a clean
and easy to organized way it's a thing
that's been around forever and people
don't use nearly as often as they should
so I really want to recommend like think
about where you can apply it and you
know there are various implementations
around oh camel has a very nice one but
there are others as well
but I think it's totally worth thinking
about that as a tool you can add to your
toolbox and finally a thing you'll
notice is throughout this talk is diff
in patch had a surprisingly large part
in the overall story they showed up over
and over again they show up in the
virtual Dom they show up in a number of
different ways inside of the incremental
Dom world and a key if you like zoom out
and think about the larger version of
this when you think about the server
side of this problem and you think about
how you like serializes data over the
network diff and patch over and over
show up as a way of bridging
computational worlds of taking
functional data structures and mapping
them on to incremental computations or
network protocols
or imperative API is like the Dom API
and it is I think is a general-purpose
lesson that you can use in lots of
different contexts different dipping and
patching works nicely in a functional
context and it's just a very useful way
of coordinating so as I said mostly this
talk is meant to be about the ideas but
there's also a concrete software you can
like download this on your machine and
build like the example application is
just like grabbed from the open source
repo and built on my box you don't have
to use James fruits infrastructure to do
this so at the minimum its thing you can
go and look at and experiment with on
your own so that's all I've got thank
you very much
[Applause]